Do you just think this is inevitable? I
mean, is this what we're going to be
living with
basically forever or is it Yeah.
That's you know, that's of course the
question on everyone's mind.
And all you know, I'm just going to
respond to it from a theological and
again historical point of view by giving
you the long picture which is as again
that Islam is doctrinally at odds with
everyone.
They can't live in peace.
You may recall Samuel Huntington in his
um uh in his major book wrote you know,
that the borders of Islam are bloody.
Okay, because they can't live in peace
with their neighbors. Well, there's a
reason for that and it goes back to the
Creed and the doctrine that I explained
which is Islam is inherently
expansionist.
That's just the name of the game and
it's also supremacist. It's not out to
coexist.
Look around what's happening in Europe.
You have all these Muslims that go
there. They're not there to assimilate.
They're not there to you know, get
along. They're there you know, just
recently in London they had this mass
prayer demonstration, you know,
basically claiming public space and
making a you know, a point. That's the
religion. Okay, it's always been like
that. There's no surprise. So So on the
one hand we can argue that you know, no
matter what one says um a place like
Iran by a virtue of its religious belief
makes itself an enemy. No matter what.
And it gets even trickier and more
complicated because
you may be familiar with the term
taqiyya
which um it's it basically it's another
doctrine that permits Muslims to deceive
Right.
>> the non-Muslims. It's very intricate and
I've written a lot about it and uh you
know, it it it's all Muslims do it. But
the the ones who truly it's almost um
you know, second nature to are the
Shiites.
And the reason for that is because
they're the minority sect. So living
amongst Sunnis for centuries right from
the beginning
they had a lot of reason to dissemble.
And so a lot of their dissembling has
become so internalized
that it my point is it's a very
important for me
it would be very difficult to take at
face value what a Shia is telling me
especially with what I know about Islam.
Okay. And again, you know, I'm giving
you I'm not even closely following
what's happening. These are more like
general principles and sort of
philosophical theological views that I'm
sharing. So yeah, on the one hand Islam
makes itself the enemy. On the other
hand, you know, say what you want but
Islam also teaches deception especially
Shia Islam. In fact, a lot of people
apologists will argue with me and say
no, taqiyya the Muslims don't do taqiyya
only Shias do it. Actually, they all do
it but the Shias are the ones who truly
pioneered it.
Bring back the
flames. Bring back the
>> [music]
>> flames. Bring back the
flames in
your righteous
name.